Alexis Moussine-Pouchkine: Hi, everyone.
We're here at Devoxx
2014, and I'm here
with people that know a
thing or two about Java.
And I think you guys have
read "Effective Java," right?
EAMONN MCMANUS: Yes.
CHRISTIAN GRUBER: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: So this is
Eamonn, this is Christian.
And we're going to talk about
annotation processing, code
generation, and two
specific projects.
So why don't we start with
annotation processing?
So for those that haven't
been exposed to it,
you want to explain
what that is?
EAMONN MCMANUS: Sure.
So it's something
that was introduced
as a standard with Java 6.
So there was a JSR
that defined that,
and there's a set of
APIs that define it.
And it's basically a way of
extending the Java processor,
plugging your own code
into the processor that
will run while
compilation is running.
And it's quite powerful.
You can follow
these standard APIs
which will work with
both Java SE and ECJ
because it is a standard.
And you can arrange that
when the compilation happens
your code gets
executed, and that code
can see what other
code is being compiled.
And it can also
generate new code
that will be compiled
alongside the original code.
So doing that means
that you can-- first
of all, you can do
additional checks,
because you can
emit error messages,
and they will show up
in the right place.
If you were using an IDE, they
would show up as red lines,
there is a problem here.
And secondly, then you can
augment the code, the input
code of your program, with
this new generated code.
MALE SPEAKER: So the fact that
it's at the compiler level
obviously means that you still
get the benefit of using,
you mentioned an IDE,
and all the tool chain.
And that is very critical.
How about performance?
Is that something that
people need to worry about?
EAMONN MCMANUS:
It's not something
that we've noticed
as a problem, so I
think it's probably all right.
MALE SPEAKER: So the
reason you were here
talking about
annotation processing,
and that we're
talking about it now,
is that this enables for
some interesting features.
And one of the projects
you've been working on
is AutoValue, is
the proper name?
EAMONN MCMANUS: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: And that's
a project on its own?
Can we say it's built
by the Guava team?
Some relation to it?
CHRISTIAN GRUBER: It's part
of a larger effort of projects
that all do
annotation processing
for various purposes.
AutoValue does value type.
Really easy, low
boilerplate value types.
I
MALE SPEAKER: So, yeah.
I mean, AutoValue, I mentioned
"Effective Java." if you
haven't read it, guys
watching this and gals,
you should read it.
It talks about how
you have to implement
equals hashcode-- what
was the third one?
EAMONN MCMANUS: Two string.
MALE SPEAKER: Two string.
Thank you.
EAMONN MCMANUS: And that's
a major pain, right?
MALE SPEAKER: And
that is painful, yes.
But remind us, why do
you need to do that?
And how are you solving this?
EAMONN MCMANUS: So
you don't absolutely
have to implement two
string, but you really
would want to implement equals
and hashcode so that you
can use your values as keys
in like hash map or hash set.
If you have equals, that
means you can use it in tests.
So you can compare your object
against an expected object,
and so on.
So you pretty much always
want to define these methods
when you're creating
a value type.
So an immutable type, you really
want to define these methods.
And it's a huge pain,
because you're doing it
exactly the same way every time.
So the idea of
AutoValue is, instead
of-- so you define basic
abstract methods that
are the properties
of your objects.
So your classes and address,
you say abstract class address.
And you say abstract
string, street address,
abstract post code and so on.
And you put the AutoValue
annotation on that class.
And so the idea with the
AutoValue annotation processor
is that it sees this
notation, and that
causes it to generate
basically new code,
which is the implementation
of this class.
So you have this abstract
class, which is the interface
that the client code sees.
And then you can have a
private implementation
of that class, a
subclass that basically
writes those methods for you.
So it writes the implementations
of those two abstract methods
that you defined, and it also
writes the implementation
of the equals and hashcode
and two string methods.
So it's a simple idea, but
it's just a huge benefit
in terms of avoiding
having to rewrite
the same sorts of things
over and over again.
MALE SPEAKER: So if I want to
use it, it's like [INAUDIBLE],
I add-- how does it--
EAMONN MCMANUS: The easiest
way to do it is with Maven.
I mean, you just express a
dependency on it with Maven,
and everything just works.
MALE SPEAKER: This has no impact
on any jar that you generate,
right?
This is all tooling.
EAMONN MCMANUS:
Yes, that's right.
CHRISTIAN GRUBER:
This is tooling.
Although the generated
code goes in your jar.
We actually made a choice
to generate source code,
not bite code, precisely
so you could go look at it.
MALE SPEAKER: But you're not
carrying along a library, or--
CHRISTIAN GRUBER: No, no, no.
MALE SPEAKER: this
huge dependency.
EAMONN MCMANUS:
AutoValue in particular
is defined to be
completely standalone.
It doesn't depend
on anything else
in terms of what's generated.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
Java 6 and above.
CHRISTIAN GRUBER: And you're
configuring the compiler
with the jar, you're not
configuring your runtime
with the jar.
MALE SPEAKER: Right, exactly.
It's really the compile time.
CHRISTIAN GRUBER:
Yeah, for sure.
MALE SPEAKER: So there's more to
it than just [INAUDIBLE] this.
I know there's some
nice additional features
that people might want to
use that is part of this.
So when it comes to declaring
things as being nullable,
for example?
EAMONN MCMANUS: Right, so it
does do a certain amount of--
MALE SPEAKER: Optionally?
EAMONN MCMANUS: Optionally, yes.
If you don't specify a
parameter as nullable,
then the generated
constructor would actually
verify that it's not null.
So there's a few
things like that.
We have GWT serialization, G-W-T
serialization, for example.
So a few extra bells and
whistles like that, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So if you haven't
checked it out--
and what is the status
of that project?
CHRISTIAN GRUBER: It's
in a release candidate.
And we had a
discussion yesterday
where we couldn't think of a
good reason not to release 1.0.
So I suspect we'll release
1.0 really soon now.
MALE SPEAKER: You
heard it here first.
Really soon now.
CHRISTIAN GRUBER:
There's a little bit
of touching up in terms of
the other features and maybe
some documentation improvements.
But we've been using it in
production code at Google
for quite awhile now, at head.
And it hasn't changed much
in the last couple of months.
MALE SPEAKER: And it is an
open sourced project developed
[INAUDIBLE].
CHRISTIAN GRUBER:
It's on GitHub.
It's GitHub, in the Google
project space, called Auto,
A-U-T-O.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, great.
So let's switch gears
a little bit and talk
about something,
Christian, you've
been spending some time
on, which is Dagger.
Which is, really
when you look at it,
another use of annotation
processing, where a lot of work
is done at the compile time so
that, in terms of performance
start up time and
many other things,
you don't have to
do it at run time.
So tell us what is Dagger real
quickly, and how it uses ABT.
CHRISTIAN GRUBER:
Yeah, so Dagger
is, in essence, a
JSR 330 compliant
dependency injection framework.
MALE SPEAKER: At inject.
CHRISTIAN GRUBER: At inject.
You, just like every other
dependency injection framework
these days you have classes
that you control the constructor
for, and you can mark at
inject on the constructor.
And then they declare
their dependencies
as constructor parameters.
Or you have a
configuration for things
that can't have
constructors, like interfaces
that need to be bound.
And we have some
annotations at module
for the module
configuration classes,
and at provides to
declare the methods that
will provide these types that
you don't have constructors
for.
And what it does is it looks
at these annotation signals
and says, hey, what
are the dependencies
that were declared?
And can we satisfy these with
all of the things that we know?
And then it just does
that work for you.
So traditionally, things
like Spring and Juice,
et cetera, would use
reflection at run time
to analyze these signals
and yank them all together.
And what we wanted
was, first of all,
to have some improved
performance on Android.
And reflection is
pretty slow on dalvik,
and so that was one of
the inceptions of Dagger,
one of the motivations for it.
Secondly, we wanted to
move errors from runtime,
late in the game,
to compile times.
It's always good to move
your errors forward.
And with annotation
processors, we
found a way that
we could generate
code that could do what
the reflection did.
Because we did the reflective
analysis at compile time.
And we could also omit
the errors and warnings,
as Eamonn mentioned, so we
could actually turn these wiring
errors that you
would normally have
to do some kind of
an internal logging
system, or an
internal observation,
to figure out what
is my wiring, you
can now see it at compile time.
You know when you got it wrong.
And it'll catch cycles and
all of these sorts of things.
MALE SPEAKER: So you mentioned
that mobile and Android
in particular was
the prime motivation.
CHRISTIAN GRUBER: That
was the original, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: The original one.
So has this evolved?
Because it sounds like--
CHRISTIAN GRUBER:
It has involved.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
There are a number of
things you cannot do,
because you're doing
stuff at compile time.
So you cannot be
as dynamic, and--
CHRISTIAN GRUBER: Yeah.
And to be clear,
we've never had it
as a goal to be as fully
dynamic as the runtime based
dependency injection systems.
Like Juice will always
have more capabilities,
because it can dynamically
slurp things up
at the last minute,
which we will never
be able to do quite the same.
Although we found that a lot
of places where we were using
reflection, like graph
analysis for example,
that we're doing
at compile time,
there are other kinds of, sort
of the assembling of new things
that is often done at
reflection, that we found
we can also do at compile time.
So we have some people that
had implemented plug-in systems
on top of Juice, and they
were trying to use Dagger.
And they were like,
well how do we do that?
Because we can't
dynamically build the shell
around this thing,
because it's static.
And they just
turned their plug-in
into a Dagger-like
annotation processor system
so they would generate
dagger modules which
then our processor would
generate the resulting DI
code for.
And it just works amazingly
well for that sort of thing.
So we just kept pushing the
reflection problem further out
and got a lot of the
benefits and even layers
on top of dagger.
It was kind of fascinating.
MALE SPEAKER: So same
question is for AutoValue.
What is Dagger 2?
We're talking mostly about
Dagger 2 here by the way.
CHRISTIAN GRUBER:
I should mention,
so Dagger 1 did the exact same
thing that we're talking about.
But Dagger 2, we went
fully compile time.
There was still
some loading that
was going on in
reflection, and we've
eliminated all of
that with Dagger 2.
MALE SPEAKER: And
then where are we now?
Can I use Dagger 2?
What has Google been doing in
terms of contributing and using
Dagger 2?
CHRISTIAN GRUBER: So Dagger
1 was a joint project
with Google and Square.
Dagger 2 is still
a joint project
in that Square has been
consulting with us and helping,
and we've been workshopping all
of the ideas with the Square
guys.
But primarily,
the implementation
has been written inside Google.
We are using it in production
on a couple of servers
and quite a few Android
applications, Dagger 2.
So at head, it works.
It's missing a lot
of important things,
like the validations
aren't fully built out.
So if you get errors,
sometimes in your graph
you'll sometimes
get a stack trace
where you should
get a nice error.
And that's just stuff we
have to improve and work on.
It's in a pre-alpha state.
We haven't released
a formal alpha,
but we are pushing snapshots to
Sonatype snapshot repositories.
So if you use Maven, you can use
Dagger 2 as 2.0 dash snapshot
version, and you'll just
get the latest from head.
Every time we push to GitHub,
we get a new version pushed out
to Sonatype automatically.
MALE SPEAKER: For
those people that
have an issue with snapshots,
how long would it be before--?
CHRISTIAN GRUBER: We're
hoping to put together
some sort of developer's preview
in the next couple of weeks.
MALE SPEAKER: A couple of weeks.
CHRISTIAN GRUBER:
We've just updated
the documentation
on the website.
So it is actually-- there is
some documentation now for 2.0.
So you can get a sense
of how to use it.
Now that we've done
a couple of talks,
and Jake Wharton's
doing a talk later today
here at the conference.
So we think people
will be in good shape
to receive a developer preview
in the next couple of weeks.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
CHRISTIAN GRUBER: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So
I guess that's all
the time we have for questions.
Eamonn, thank you very much.
AutoValue, Dagger, all powered
by annotation processing.
And with super low overhead, no
runtime dependency whatsoever.
So thanks for
answering my questions.
EAMONN MCMANUS: Yeah, pleasure.
MALE SPEAKER: And do
check out those projects.
Thank you very much.
EAMONN MCMANUS: Thank you.
CHRISTIAN GRUBER: Thanks.